لذلك نرى مدخل 1 شبكات تحت الأرض
الانفاق ومدينة الفكر تشتتكم
المقرات العسكرية
دعنا نذهب إلى الطابق السفلي ونرى كيف كل شيء هناك
حول تم ترتيبها
وإيلاء الاهتمام وضع نفسه لديه
الكائن هنا هو فرع واحد من النفق
وها هي الثانية
ليس الكثير من الأضواء كيف تأتي هنا
لذلك تم تجهيزها
نفق جميع الصفائح المعدنية مكدسة
تذهب أبعد من النفق من حيث المبدأ
في مكان ما لعدة كيلومترات
ها هو النفق الثاني ينخفض
مثيرة للاهتمام حتى جعلوا الطريق وضعت
كل ما يقوله جميل مثل الباركيه
يتصاعد قليلا متعرجة هنا بالفعل
حروب أغلقت هذا بالذات
مثال غرفة التخزين
جميع الأسلحة اللازمة في واحدة من
تحتوي هذه الخطوط أيضًا على مستشفى ميداني
تم تجهيز المسلحين تحت الأرض في كل مكان
كانت المعدات مثل هذه الغرفة الصغيرة حيث
يجلس الحارس
في الواقع ممتلئ
نقطة تفتيش